U.S household debt and Q3 soared by 351
billion dollars at fastest Pace in 15
years
during the third quarter at the fastest
Pace in 15 years due to Hefty increases
in credit card usage and mortgage
balances the Federal Reserve reported
Tuesday the total debt jumped 351
billion dollars from July to September
the largest nominal quarterly increase
since 2007 bringing the collective
household ious in the U.S to Fresh 16
and a half trillion dollars that's an
increase of 2.2 percent from the
previous quarter 8.3 percent from a year
ago the increase follows a 310 billion
dollar jump in a second quarter and
represents 1.27 trillion dollar annual
increase Tom what's going on over there
well this is a sign of what is happening
with inflation to the average American
um and they're turning to their credit
cards let me connect some Dots here
there's there's a couple quick points
for y'all first of all we see a headline
on this boy look at this jumping debt
well what's going on then you turn to
Walmart and Target earnings I dove into
both of them Walmart very telling they
said apparel dropped Home Improvement
and Home Goods dropped that's called
discretionary and Goldman Sachs came out
and said we're seeing discretionary
spending drop we don't think interest
rates are going to Peak until May where
the FED they believe is going to make it
five and a quarter so they're looking at
a half a point in December quarter
points to start the year capping at five
and a quarter in May why is that
important well where's all this debt
it's on credit cards so I went and
looked up the Visa and MasterCard
earnings from three weeks ago guess what
they're both up in the middle of all
this and they said consumer spending was
strong but even Visa said it's what
they're spending on they're spending on
groceries and when you dive into the
Walmart story was very interesting they
said that there is a shift in proteins
because remember Walmart and Target
compete but Walmart is like 45 Grocery
and Target is not Target's got sodas and
chips and some groceries but nothing
compared to Walmart so you would expect
Target to be harder hit if discretionary
so I looked that up guess what they were
so Walmart is seeing people move to
groceries they have analysts and a lot
of their customers and they even said
that by their analytics hundred thousand
dollar customers were moving to Walmart
branded groceries for Staples like flour
you know that the generic Walmart brand
on flower baby formula diapers they said
the Walmart house Brands were doing
better than the more premium prices
typically 10 to 20 percent cheaper is
that a fair number to say totally fair
number yeah absolutely so what we're
seeing this spending is saying that
consumers are putting a lot of inflation
on the credit card number one it should
one man's interest is another man's
ebitda think about that Pat the interest
on a credit card becomes ebitda for a
Visa that's a good point and it showed
up in their earnings report you know
yesterday while I'm in DC I'm talking to
a bunch of these folks and I said so let
me ask you a question what's the biggest
thing you're concerned about the room is
about 70 percent uh women you hear
ladies saying grocery shopping has gone
up I said I said what do you mean by it
yep a
milk today 529 to buy milk and it was
three dollars last year I said what do
you mean milk has gone up from whatever
was three bucks to 529 the first thing
they talked about was milk I mean you
have to these are mothers these are
parents these are sitting there saying
what they're got to be doing with it and
by the way when people start spending a
little bit more on credit card what is
it saying to you it's saying uh they
kind of need it its emergency a lot of
people use their credit cards as a
source of emergency fund although
emergency funds should be an emergency
fund not a credit card so people are
leaning towards credit cards so it's
going to be interesting what happens
next quarter because whether it's
trending
towards uh this happening more uh but
it's never good when you're seeing
consumers leaning towards credit cards
now Adam what do you got to say about
this uh speaking of milk you saw our
friend Marcelo Hernandez on uh SNL this
weekend uh on uh Weekend Update he's
like milk what are you a baby who drinks
milk yeah it was so funny
um so shout out to him but it's
interesting because obviously Tom is
very very uh uh insightful when it comes
to the macroeconomics I always kind of
my expertise is more on the personal
finance what I love about saying of
personal finance it's your money
personal finance so it's interesting
because in 2020 and 2021 Tom you
probably know the exact stats but we saw
that more people were getting out of
debt more people were saving more people
were reversing the trend of how much
they're putting on credit cards and you
know stacking cash in the bank and just
like that you know after all the
stimulus all the unemployment back to
normal like 2022 let's ball out let's go
on vacation let's buy some milk let's
get crazy here so you know at the end of
the day it comes down to personal
finance and individual responsibility
when you got your tax refund and you got
your stimulus and you got your you know
you made a little extra you got your
bonus what did you do with it did you go
on vacation did you save it did you
actually pay down debt or did you kind
of just repeat the same vicious cycle of
paycheck to paycheck you know debt debt
accumulation you know what's interesting
is you talking about credit cards you
know there's this HELOC story and like
the average credit card is what 18 19
and then people are basically if you own
a home obviously there's been great
appreciation in your home equity and
your home values people are tapping into
their HELOC their home equity line of
credit and that tends to be around what
seven eight percent ish correct 775
average today there it is that's what we
got Tom those exact numbers I love it
Bingo um so that's still not a great
number order your future looks bright
hat click over here and to watch the
entire podcast click here take care
everybody
foreign
[Music]